contribution my children make to our
local community because they've been
able to stay there and the only reason
they could stay there was by having a
local need dwell in so I've given you
all the reasons why you should approve
it and I'm determined when we do do a
local plan we address some of these
issues because I can take you to our
join two adjoining districts that have a
slightly more pragmatic View
and myself and our
head of place and policy or car park man
to me but anyway we met with the
government's new directive of um looking
at how to use um Royal enablers to look
into how we can provide roal housing to
retain our young people I've been
approached by the S RSN which is
following a directive from the
government to look at Enterprise to
protect the rural areas so the whole
move movement now is how do we protect
rural areas by retaining young people
and making them viable this is a classic
case it really does deserve approval
thank you
chair thank you for those
comments got no other Regent speakers so
I open up the matter for discussion who
wouldd like to kick off yes counc Thomas
um just uh looking at the recommendation
and it talks about the fact that the
future occupants will be reliant on
private transport but I'm looking at it
on Google Maps in front of me and
there's a bus stop at the junction of
Brandis corner and four Street very
close which it says
is click on the right
bit served by number 639 and 642
boss so I'm just wondering why it says
they' be reliant
on um private trans transport if there's
a bus stop just around the corner when I
looked um they didn't seem to be that
frequent enough to be used on
week that's going be the same most
exactly I mean I would come back on that
because I always you know on so many
applications they come back and say
people you know they're not near a bus
stop and they've got to rely on their
own private use when I always say even
people in big say bord they live more
than a mile from a bus stop and they use
their cars to go into work school drop
offs and go shopping so I don't see why
people living in the Countryside should
be discriminated against used in their
cars I I obviously need a bit of
Education here because I know we have to
judge everything on its own on its own
specific needs but the application to
back would have been far better if it
had actually asked to become a local
needs application whereas this one is a
local needs application and it doesn't
work so can someone explain that to me
please yeah of course councilor Whitaker
so the F the first the second agenda
item you're right was proposing an open
market dwelling at a location that was
essentially a cluster of houses this
application yes is proposing local
needs um the only policy provision
within the local plan and that is your
starting point um is policy DM 24 which
only allows local needs dwellings at
rural settlements and now the definition
of a rural
settlement as set out in the local plan
is a small closely grouped cluster of
housing that contains at least one
identified local service or Community
facility so agend agenda item number two
it was essentially just a group of
houses with no service or facility now
with this particular
application um yes there are a closely
clustered group of houses but it doesn't
contain a service or facility now as as
the images showed there is a school in a
village hall I think you know in
relative close proximity but a true
interpretation of the policy and the
definition would be that this is not
classed as a rural settlement hence the
officer's recommendation is the white
the right one looking at the plan as a
starting point however you know officers
would certainly acknowledge that this is
a slightly unusual scenario and that you
have a local service and facility will
to which clearly serve a clear rural
area however are isolated in themel so
members may want to consider that
geography which is quite unique and
exceptional in this circumstance in in
their consideration of this application
um I think it's also important to say
frustration with the policies as they
are in the current local plan in itself
is not a reason to go against the local
plan we are moving forward with a new
local plan hopefully in November um and
that will be the time to really take a
good look at our spatial strategy how
our settlements relate to each other
what appropriate levels of development
are to ensure that we can keep young
people in our communities and keep them
vibrant however this committee must as a
starting point start with the local plan
and I think you know the the application
earlier which was refused for the open
market dwelling from an officer point of
view if that had been a local needs
dwelling the recommend recation would
have been the same because there's no no
service or facility within that grouping
but as I said this is a slightly unusual
geography here in that you have two
obvious local services and Community
facilities which aren't within hence
it's not a rural settlement but they're
very close I hope that answered your
question councelor whiter yeah thank you
very much that dides help a
bit I mean I can
um recollect but I I was two hours
trying to find an appeal decision where
a similar application and the the appeal
inspector said that um if a small rural
settlement had no
facilities then they could utilize
nearby facilities and they could share
facilities and and I could not find that
appeal decision you want me to come yes
please
um the national planning policy
framework does include so our policies
don't have a clear policy that addresses
that scenario um there was an appeal
decision I think it was at high Bullen
some time ago which isn't a rural
settlement but the inspector deemed that
a dwelling there was acceptable and that
particular inspector cited um the mppf
so if I could just find the relevant
paragraph um bear with
me so the section of the national
planning policy framework which which
clearly sets policy for across the
country and requires our local plan to
be in there is a requirement to be in
compliance so
paragraph 83 of the December 23 um mppf
States um planning policies should
identify opportunities for villages to
grow and Thrive especially where this
will support local services and the last
sentence is the important one where
there are groups of smaller settlements
development in one Village May Support
Services in a village nearby but the
important term there is Village as well
so that's that's suggesting settlements
that were of a greater scale than
necessarily a cluster of housing um but
as I said earlier I think I think
members would be it would be open to a
consideration of that unusual geography
and that you have two key services in
close proximity in this particular
case yes K
bushing can I just ask a question um of
the planner manager you were talking
about rural settlement if if this if if
this was adjacent to rural settlement
then a local needs dwelling would be the
right uh path to go
down
that that status of that settlement
would change because it is at a point in
time so we have had scenarios um with
with small groups of dwellings where
there may have been a Methodist Chapel
for example that had closed um and had
changed to a dwelling that that that
would not trigger that that
classification as a rle
settlement I didn't realize that turned
it
off what happens in a lot of these rural
settlements and you know small villages
is exactly the fact that there is no
development that's what closes the
services that's why the village shop
goes that's why the post office goes
that's why the small shops sorry the
small schools end up closing you know
and people's you know people then have
to travel that much further to access
any service such as schools day
nurseries Etc you know we talk about
sustainability it's not sustainable to
to force people to drive you know miles
and miles to access everything purely
because you know we're we're not
actually allowing development within
those sentiments you know it just seems
to me the wrong approach to take and I I
Echo what C James was saying earlier but
they there needs to be change moving
forward but however we are where we are
and we've got to deal with it with it
now but um did did the officer when she
did the the presentation stl7 stroke
four did you say that would be a policy
that could be used to Grant permission
that's
that's right okay so what about dm24
then local needs dwelling that's the one
we're talking about you can't Grant at
dm24 because there is no shop or
facility nearby so so what what I sort
of suggested in this as an exception
this case is you have an unusual
situation that you have a clear group of
dwellings that are of a Rel you know
relative scale but that those
Services namely a hall and a school are
outside it is unusual the the definition
is very clear that it should contain um
so as I said the officer's
recommendation is the right one but
members may wish to maybe
articulate a view that actually in this
case it's tantamount to a rural
settlement that we've got the village
hall and the school close by I would say
that that does that does articulate that
so I I would suggest that we ground
using dm24 on the on the grounds that it
has facilities
nearby yeah I mean I know the area quite
well and I mean you know the whole in
fact years ago we even had a plans
committee meeting at Bradford and cooky
Village Hall and it's right you know the
school's right next to it and that does
serve The Wider Comm smaller community
it is and I you know I would second
Council Bush's um recommendation that we
approve the
application yes I just wanted to ask I'm
just seen this actually and I should
have mentioned it earlier Mr Lo had Mr
Oak had local needs application approved
200 MERS away two three years ago two
years ago whatever
um in relation to the current
application was that 200 M closer to the
school and the village I mean if you can
remember it does seem a bit
odd yeah I I believe that dwelling was
in a different location it was sort of
to the would it be the South it
southeast of the group of of dwellings
um still within the within the wider
area yes I believe that was a committee
approval against officer recommendation
and also that was at a time when the
council couldn't demonstrate a fiveyear
land supp so there were different
circumstances it certainly wasn't an
officer recommendation so there is
consistency with with the officer
approach no no that's helpful I
understand now thank you obviously if we
did if this application was approved we
would have to have the condition that it
remains as a local needs yeah yeah
section 106 section
106 so that would have to be
included
um so the distance is because there's a
drainage field for the adjacent property
within that gap of approximately 10 MERS
and they've said that's why they can't
AB but it to the curtilage of the
neighboring property so that would argue
that there is a contiguous line needed
for residential use all the way to this
red box on page 37
if because can you cannot actually build
on that piece of Gade in between so we
have contiguous that runs to home you
could although it's not a continuous
built form it's it's a a patch of land
that's used for the dwelling now can I
pick up a comment that our planning
maner said and U and I think I'm quoting
you now the true
interpretation now we all have
interpretations and we all think our
interpretation is the true one and
everybody else is have got it the wrong
way around and a lot of these policies
um are there is Wile room in them to
argue all you want and and argue and I
would want to argue um that there is a
continuous the dm24 applies and thirdly
what our local plan does not recognize
is there been a huge change since covid
I see and I live in the countryside and
I see so many delivery vs now going to
our rural areas that to say there is not
a service Asda Tesco not little not
oldi but major supermarkets are
available anywhere you like in the
countryside and you have a major service
so you're denying people in rural areas
the same opportunity so I would on
balance in my interpretation of
dm24 want to
support the approval of this application
thank you
chair yeah I mean I you know when you
when you read the report I mean Deon
County highways they have been consulted
and they've got no I know um objections
with suitable conditions and
Environmental Protection have got no
objections and I say this absolutely
tongue and cheek Southwest water have
actually made
response and they have got no objections
yes Council hes just point of
information it says there a speed limit
of 60 miles hour does that relate to the
bigger Road or the one outside the
site so it's a it's a single track but
it doesn't have a 30 mph speed limit but
obviously it is very narrow and I don't
think you would do
thanks chair could could Tom put the
first slide up the site location plan
please that one if you look at the blue
line around the site around the area and
then you got the red one there if you go
to the top end of of the site hold more
cross where it says hold more cross why
couldn't
I dwelling have been cited there I just
wonder more within the built form of
that air area rather than stuck out on
its own down that end there and reading
in the report here I see there are two
objections received about the highways
Lane being too narrow single carriageway
speeds too high
um a blind corner of 90° similar
objections to application which It
quotes uh located at 100 m distant on
the opposite side of the road was
refused on on appeal so why it site why
it had to be cited there and not more
within the built form I don't know but
that's up to the applicant to decide
again with these local needs dwellings I
wish people would just put a full
application in with everything then that
we can look at in detail but just to put
an outline in for local needs because
there's lots of reasons for local needs
dwellings as we all know I mean you work
within that area you or you have a
business nearby in the area or you work
for somebody in the area who's got
business things like that all that comes
forward in an application this and
reading that um one was approved 200
MERS away back in
2021 as you say when we didn't have the
fiveyear housing land Supply then so
that was a different reason why that
obviously
got I just wish we get pH applications
in on these local needs and then you've
got all the details because the same
arguments that we had on the earlier
which was an open market dwelling site
but again only in outline all those
reasons we discussed about wanting to
support local areas and Villages I mean
I'm a big supporter of the car I take
exactly what you said about just because
you live out in the rural areas we all
need cars even as you said in B people
drive so I I'm I'm no problem with
having to travel but of course the
government put the blocks on that when
they said oh you've got to use a car
that's a black mark against having a
development that was nationally but I
just have a problem
with not knowing enough about what the
local needs is really I I'd like to know
exactly what the rather than just
somebody who lives or has family
nearby um I'd like to know far more
about and and if we have that
information for me it's much easier to
make a proper
decision right any other further
comments it has been proposed by Council
Bush being seconded by myself that the
application is approved quot in
[Music]
dm24 and a section 106 agreement as to
local needs delegate conditions and
delegated normal
conditions are you happy with that
yes Council there isn't a strategic
policy supports it is DMS are just
development management yeah I mean
st73 which is um the rural spal strategy
that is the enabling strategic policy
which refers to rural settlements and
that enables policy
dm24 um as I said earlier that principle
around dm24 it has been open to members
to consider the proximity of the
services however there are the other
components um you know the the size of
the dwelling being no larger than can be
justified by the need again with no
detail it's not possible to consider
that the proximity and to the built form
these are all things that also need to
be considered and I appreciate councelor
bushby has probably thought about that
in his in his recommendation but st73
would be the Strategic policy that would
then enable policy
dm24
yes Council I mean I'm happy to stretch
the definition of the rural
settlement if I had all the information
that's my problem that I don't have
enough information to be able to do that
stretch that policy about rural
settlement right your points are noted
Council Lether so as been proposed by
Council Bush we seconded by myself that
the applications approved quoting st73
dm2 4 and with the section 106 that it
remains as a local needs
do all so we now go to vote all those in
favor of
approval recorded vote yeah yeah thank
you chair councel
back for councelor bushby for councelor
haes councelor
leather against councelor lock for
councelor Pennington for coun
Thomas councelor weatley four councelor
Whitaker
against that's six for chair and three
against thank you very much right I
think that is the end of the
applications
so we go on to appeal decisions which
are on pages 52 to 88 hases anyone got
any comments on appeal
decisions
yeah they're on a good
run item number eight dedicated admb
Pages 89 to
90 and then item number nine the
planning decisions Pages 91 to 110 and
those
are between the 23rd of November 23 to
the 24th of January so page
99 100
109 and
110 what